hello you preached the provincial Health
Services Authority telephone line for
medical assistance and dying the
countdown to Joni cowie's death has
begun
she called the number on the government
website they will provide doctors that
will sign off for you like many disabled
Canadians she is stuck in a cycle of
poverty and despair it's no hope for
anybody in Ontario that's a good boy so
she's planning to end her life up with
the government's help they can have me
dead in 90 days
that's what I was told like in my case
the problem is not really the disability
it is the poverty Les Landry is in the
same position wanting to live but
buddying no other option than death
these two are from asthma this is for my
COPD since when did we stop looking at
the value of human life in this country
it's a question people with disability s
and their Advocates ask constantly we
can organize medical assistance in dying
in approximately two weeks in a very
organized and efficient manner yet it is
so difficult to get my patients the
social support that they need to live
well that is morally distressing
from her home in Windsor Ontario Joni
deals with the grinding Financial pain
of living in poverty during an
affordability crisis compounded by the
physical pain of disability I have
severe severe asthma that's turned into
COPD and Guillain-Barre syndrome as well
as cancer
I also just recently fractured my back
I'm tired a lot the pain is excruciating
and he told me
Joni lives with her three dogs and her
daughter who was also disabled they have
no family support so they have to find a
way to survive on
1228 a month Joni gets from Ontario's
disability Support Program plus a few
hundred dollars more for her daughter
even with subsidized housing it's not
nearly enough we have about 59 left to
buy broke groceries in a month because
our home we have to have housing
Insurance rent
Hydro is high gas is high
I get angry at people who say you need
to budget better because I just want to
say to them
go to hell
I really do and I don't swear very often
here's the thing Joni's Financial
struggle is not at all unique during the
pandemic the government decided working
Canadians needed at least two thousand
dollars a month to Live While the
disabled were forced to get by on much
less they had served but not for people
with disabilities people with
disabilities have been put on the back
burner
and nobody gives a damn about them
disability supports vary from Province
to Province on the low end imagine
surviving on 705 dollars a month as
people with disabilities do in New
Brunswick or how about living on
1358 a month in Vancouver where the
average rent for a one-bedroom apartment
is twenty five hundred dollars the most
recent numbers from statistics Canada
reveal 41 percent of Canadians living
under the poverty line have a disability
that's more than 1.5 million people
about the population of Montreal our
social assistance rates place people
with disabilities below the poverty line
approximately 25 percent below the
poverty line so honestly this is
legislative poverty for people with
disabilities this is the kind of care
that's needed Dr nahid Dasani is a
palliative care physician and professor
of community and family medicine at the
University of Toronto he gave us a tour
of the East Toronto neighborhood where
he offers street-based care often to
people with disabilities living in
poverty many of the people we care for
are dealing with serious illnesses but
often they're very sick because of their
social circumstances there are
significant Health outcomes if we don't
address those issues and treat those
issues the result Dr dosani is
increasingly discussing maid or or
medical assistance in
not necessarily because they want to die
but because they see no way out of the
twin miseries of poverty and disability
when people are living in such a
situation where they're structurally
placed in poverty is medical assistance
and dying really a choice or is it
coercion under Canada's first medical
assistance in dying law passed in 2016 a
person's death had to be quote
reasonably foreseeable to be approved
last year eligibility was expanded to
people who have a quote serious and
irreversible illness or disability that
causes intolerable suffering now people
like Joni qualify on social media it's a
constant conversation but almost
everyone is like yeah and just kind of
wait and see you know how it is in six
months gonna see how it is in eight
months we'd like to make it to a year
but I don't think we're going to make it
to a year I've cried a lot at night I
usually stay up a lot at night I pray I
pray a lot it
in medicine had Alberta Les Landry is
contemplating made and leaving behind
his beloved service dog Annie
Les has been growing steadily poorer and
more desperate since his career as a
truck driver was derailed more than a
decade ago disability can happen to
anyone at any time I'm doing good I was
making good money 80 85 Grand here I
developed a hernia and then that's when
the surgery happened that's when the
blood pressure went out of control
that's why I developed epilepsy and the
three mini strokes and things just fell
apart good girl on Alberta's disability
program Les was receiving
1685 dollars a month plus benefits for
his service dog special diet and
medications with my blister back along
with timely donations from strangers on
Twitter he was just scraping by that's
for a week then in may he turned 65 in
the bureaucratic Shuffle he was
transitioned from disability to senior
status and actually lost some benefits I
am no longer a person with a disability
I am a senior citizen in poverty in in
the past less planned ahead made extra
payments on his bills but he's no longer
able to do that and is forced to rely
even more on donations the big pictures
if I didn't plan ahead and make them
extra payments I'd probably be homeless
I cannot live the rest of my life on the
Goodwill of friends on Twitter no less
Joni and many other disabled Canadians
who share their stories with global news
say they aren't against medically
assisted dying in principle but they say
Canada should have raised disability
benefits before expanding access to it
they targeted people with disabilities
and people with chronic pain and I said
if you're going to do that have a
responsibility to also lift the benefits
and increase the quality of life for
people at this place the people you are
targeting we should prioritize health
care and social support that promotes
the human rights of all Trudeau lemons
is a professor of health law and policy
at the University of Toronto he has been
warning the Canadian government for
years that the speed and scope of its
plans to expand access to assisted dying
was a violation of the rights of
disabled Canadians out of a misplaced
form of compassion we think that persons
with disabilities have a reason to end
their life earlier than others this
basically is is a is discriminatory only
about a dozen countries have legalized
doctor-assisted death lemon says the few
that allow it for patients who aren't
terminally ill have stronger protections
than Canada against coercion and
suffering caused by poverty in my view
we're actually failing to implement even
some of the most basic safeguards that
that at least exist in those countries
Belgium and the Netherlands have had
assisted dying since the early 2000s
[Music]
doctors are forbidden from suggesting it
to patients they must also exhaust all
other options before approving it we're
getting rid of this idea that we'll
first try the least interventionist
measures I find that actually quite
extraordinary that we've forgotten I
think the seriousness of ending the life
of a person as a measure to relieve
their suffering as Canada has opened up
eligibility the number of cases has shot
up in 2021 more than ten thousand
Canadians opted for a medically assisted
death that's a 32 percent increase from
the year before the numbers have
increased faster here than any other
country where it's legal including the
Netherlands and Belgium so even though
those countries have been practicing
medical assistant and dying our
euthanasia for 20 years they are at the
rate that we have after only a couple of
years there is no way of knowing how
many of those deaths could have been
avoided with the right supports but we
know there are some recently in Canada
an Ontario woman suffering from chemical
sensitivities reportedly opted for a
medically assisted death because she
couldn't afford appropriate housing and
in another troubling case a Veterans
Affairs employee suggested it to a
veteran who was seeking help for PTSD
and a traumatic brain injury often I
hear arguments well this is not
impacting that many people but you know
what if it affects one person that's way
too many people and we need to do
something about that the controversy
surrounding maid is not going away in
March the government plans to expand
access yet again to include people with
mental illnesses
pork may be coming a new Canada
disability benefit is before Parliament
for the second time it was dropped last
year when a federal election was called
said but Joni and Les are skeptical we
already know seniors will not be
eligible this government has a history
on how they treat people with
disabilities 18 to 65. that excludes me
and anybody in my in my situation
sorry please speak up to your Member of
Parliament
to your members of provincial Parliament
disabilities don't ask for their
disability
I don't want to die
I don't want to go there
I just can't see me living like this for
the rest of my life